pylor mcgill as we mentioned
uh he has pitched really wonderfully for
the mets and really had his first
um
smack smackdown or the giants took it to
him and like any pitcher you get to them
early give up the four home runs we'll
see how he bounces back little shift on
against thomas and the ground ball into
the shift right at lindor he handles the
first chance low throw and scoop
beautifully by alonso for the first out
of the day
the 0-1 driven in the air to left field
fairly deep pilar back in front of the
track makes the catch as he crosses onto
the warding track and there are two men
away
runner on the move change up away balls
in center field juan soto does get up
[Music]
brandon nimmo was playing pretty far
away from where that throw ended up so
juan soto rips a bag goes to third on
the error
eighth pitch of the back coming from
mcgill to bell
and he sucks one out to center field
chasing nimmo back the left room
and a step out of the warning track to
grab it that retires the side hill gets
around the lead off walk in the stolen
base it's eric's seventh career start
against new york and still trying to get
a decision on the w side against them
for the first time well he's had two w's
in a row so that's good allowed one
earned run on six hits
with a career high ten strikeouts last
start against the marlins that was
august 24th earned the five to one win
fed he's into the wine of the pitch
breaking ball pulling the ground bell
the first baseman has it he'll flip to
fetty coming over
for the out 3-1 if you're scoring
rolls it over right side
backhand by garcia it was kind of taking
him toward escobar there still the 4-6
and pete lines one toward the middle of
basic
the door pulls in at second
i just think that garcia off the bit of
pereira and that'll move the runners up
just a boxed pitch by tres barrera so
the pass ball puts runners at second and
third two out now it's full to conforto
the door
on each of the last two pitches has come
about two-thirds of the way down the
line from third base
and elindora trying to coax a ball
he got it he got the ball that's exactly
what he was trying to do fetty did not
step off properly lindor comes home with
the first run of the game on a ball
and mcgill goes upstairs to strikeout
hernandez he's only drafted three years
ago and throws four fastballs in a row
and just blows away kibo
swinging a high pop-up shallow center
lindor backing up nimo coming in lindor
under it and the shortstop makes the
two-hand catch side retired
swing and a miss and mcgill strikes out
pereira one-two pitch swinging a slow
roller toward first just kicked behind
the bag as alonso grabs it flips
underhand to mcgill
and he goes down swinging another
fastball strikeout for tyler mcgill
right
3-2 to mcgill and he chops one toward
the middle of the diamond and it goes
off the glove of garcia and mcgill's got
another hit
how about that
he's now five for 18.
in on his hands for the pop-up
that's escobar out first so garcia peels
off
he's hit in the air to right field
toward the line soto moves a couple of
steps now back pedaling toward the
warning track he makes the catch
well that's a great breaking ball he
tripled up on a good hitter
got the strikeout fetty three k's on the
day
and the first time do 100 strikeouts in
his big league cabera
lifted toward left center field charging
over pilar comes in makes the catch
and retires escobar josh bell will come
up gabe won a pretty good ride to deep
center in the first inning tracked down
by nimmo
here it comes and this one cracked in
the air to straight away center and deep
on the run nimmo going back looking up
and it's gone josh bell has home run
number 22 to give the nationals the lead
two to one on the first pitch from
mcgill he hits that one just to the left
of the apple and the 408 mark in dead
center field
and pete smacks that one toward left
center field that's down for a base hit
cut off nicely by thomas and pete is two
for two and looks like pete is kind of
uh bad is kind of waking up a little bit
so one out and one on now baez
bias rockets one forget that that is way
way out of here
well up into the second deck javi bias
puts a charge into one and the mets go
in front three to two what a shot
second of the series 26th of the year
for baez he got a curve ball to hit and
he hit it out of
sight now the pitch defending is pointed
out in front of the plate it's picked up
by mazika throwing to second out there
throw to first not in time oh i don't
know if his foot was on the bag ever
two on one out lindor came off the bag
2-2 to thomas
struck him out
went upstairs with a changeup to strike
him out now we'll face el city's escobar
who is old for two
and a week ground ball lindor comes in
to snag it gets the force here's
jonathan vr
he's bounced to first pop to short first
pitch by fetty hit high in the air to
straight away center thomas going back
it's deep he's at the track he's at the
wall he jumps and he can't get it it
stays in play hits the fence ricochets
back into the outfield picked up by
thomas they are around second digging
for third escobar's throw the slide he
is safe at third a three-base hit for
jonathan vr but now the mets have two in
scoring position and alonso coming up
and he lines one to right field for a
base in vr is in nimble will be held at
third pivolonzo with his third hit of
the day and rbi single to make it four
to two new york one shoulder with a walk
and an rbi one for two against loop
career
soto on a pitch outer half nemo watching
see
you
later juan soto says josh bell you hit
your 22nd so will i and then answer back
to within a run one man away and
metz will
go to the bench here and dom smith is
going to bet for aaron luke now the
pitch
breaking ball hit on the ground up the
middle a base hit going into center
field around third pallar he'll come
home to score easily as the throw goes
to second and on at first with a pinch
hit rbi single is dominic smith and the
mets now have a five to three lead
the going to turn around and bat
left-handed
one the r cracks one to left center
field back in the gap that'll hit off
the wall
racing for third is smith he'll stop
there vr slides and he's safe for the
double third base umpire diaz single
home run and vr is going to circle the
bases let's see where this one hit he
better be right with this yes it was
indeed off the m m sign that is a home
run so vr with a triple and a home run
in back to back at bat
that ball is hit hard to left
double homer game
it hits above the orange line it appears
and the umpires are signaling home run
so josh bell
see
you
later back to back walks after the solo
homer by bell
brings the tying run of the plate
one two coming
and he struck him out
the door smacks one down the line toward
the corner that's a fair ball off the
wall mizika is here right behind him is
vr it's a 2-1 double for francisco
lindor
his first two rbis is coming off the
injured list
one and two to thomas
embry delivers swung on and missed
strike three put up the books
the vets have taken this series from the
nationals two games to one as they win
the final two of the series